- Speaking of true love
though, at Christmas,
my next guests have written
the perfect holiday love story.
It's called "Whiteout,"
and it's a collaboration
between six of the most
successful Black female authors
in young adult fiction
(audience claps and cheers)
Two of them are with us now.
Please welcome Angie Thomas
and Nicola Yoon, everybody.
(all clapping)
- Thank you.
- So, meet Poppy.
- Hi.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Meet Linda.
- [Poppy] Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- With six authors, who writes what?
How do you choose that?
- Well, Dhonielle is our
Tony Stark brain operation.
(all laughing)
Yeah, she likes to say
she has executive skills.
We'll call it that.
(all laughing)
- You say she's bossy.
- Bossy.
- A little bit bossy.
- Yeah, she's bossy.
But with "Blackout," she saw
that there were all these,
there was a lack of stories
about Black kids falling in love,
and her niece wanted that.
And so she said, you know,
"Why don't we all take
a trope and write it?"
Because these are, you know,
like best friends falling
in love, enemies to lovers,
these sort of things.
We don't get to see Black
kids doing that a lot.
And so she assigned us
tropes, and she was like,
"All right, this is
what I want you to do."
And so we did the same
thing with "Whiteout,"
and it was just so much
fun getting to, you know,
write these stories about
these different kids,
and they're all connected.
So it's not, we call it a novel
as opposed to an anthology.
- Right, yeah.
With chapters instead
of like short stories
because they're all connected,
and they're all leading to one big goal.
- Oh, this reminds me
of like "Love Actually."
Yeah, how they all,
and this is like one of
my favorite films ever.
And it, I just, I love when films do that
or stories do that, it somehow
all ties together at the end.
That's so clever.
- Right, and it's like
kind of a little mystery,
you don't know how it's
gonna fit together.
and it's such a nice payoff
when you see it come together.
And it's a big, like there's
a lot of kissing in this book.
It's like
a big romantic love story.
- Nothing wrong with that,
Nicola.
(all laughing)
Nothing wrong with a smooch.
- The more kissing,
the better, right?
- Yeah.
So both of you write with
teen readers in mind.
So, what stories inspire you?
Is it like maybe kids you know?
Like maybe, she said her niece, right,
is how this all kind of happened right?
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm inspired just by
young people in general.
They are so amazing.
We have to give this generation credit.
And, you know, and there's
so many types of stories
you can tell about them.
So many may have so many
different experiences,
and I think as adults we would
be doing them a disservice
if we only told one kind of story.
And so it's just, it's respecting them,
respecting what they love
respecting that they
fall in love, you know,
respecting that they,
you know, have arguments,
and that they have their
drama, whatever it may be.
Respecting that and
saying, "You know what?
I'm gonna give you a mirror. Here you go.
You're awesome.
Hopefully, I show you how awesome you are
a little bit more."
- Yeah.
And you have the opportunity
(audience clapping and cheering)
to represent so many
different kinds of people.
'Cause all the stories, you
know, they come together,
but, you know, just
like in "Love Actually,"
there's so many different,
you know, lives going on,
so many different walks of life.
That's kind of cool too.
- Well, I mean,
what happens I think when you
see stories with Black kids,
you see the same kind of story, right?
But Black kids fall in love.
Like I fell in love every day as a child,
like a teenager, right?
- Yeah, you are my daughter.
(Nicola laughs)
- Right, so we fall in
love, we're vulnerable,
we like kissing, we fall
in love with ourselves.
We deserve forgiveness and second chances.
You know, we deserve the big
spoony aspirational love story,
and we don't see enough of those.
So this is our love letter
to those kids to say,
"Hey, we know you fall in
love. Like we did too."
- They wanna see themselves though
in that story.
- Yeah, they do.
- I agree. I think that's so cool.
Backstage we have a teenage writer
who says Angie and Nicola
are her two favorite authors.
She thinks she's here to
talk about her book club,
which we shall cover, but she has no idea
they read one of her short stories
and have plenty of feedback.
So, we're going to ask
Angie and Nicola to hide
during the break, behind
a Christmas tree perhaps.
(Angie and Nicola laugh)
But stick around.
You don't wanna miss this
surprise. It's gonna be so cool.
(audience clapping)
So, my next guest
is a 10th grader and member
of the Breedlove Readers Book
Club in Syracuse, New York.
It's a book club specifically
for young Black girls
featuring a diverse range of authors.
She's also an aspiring writer
'cause I was not this cool
as a sophomore, but whatever.
Please welcome, Gabrielle, everybody.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- [Kelly] Meet Linda, meet Poppy.
- Hi.
- Nice to meet you.
- So, it's so cool,
you're like in 10th grade,
you're part of this cool book club.
So, tell me like what do y'all read?
What is the book club like?
- The book club is a Black girl book club
for girls in central New
York where we come together,
and we just share our experiences.
We read, we write, we incorporate
art projects into it all.
And I knew it was perfect for me
because my dad is a retired
pro basketball player,
and we traveled all across Europe.
We lived in Russia, Greece,
Italy, Croatia, and France.
- [Kelly] What a childhood!
- Yes, yes it was.
(chuckles) It was very fun.
And during that time I didn't
really have a constant,
so reading was that constant for me.
- That's so cool.
So, what are some of the
books that y'all have read?
- We have read "American
Street" by Ibi Zoboi.
We have read "Grown"
by Tiffany D. Jackson.
And my personal favorite is "Blackout,"
which is written by six different authors.
Two of them happen to
be my favorite authors.
Angie Thomas, actually, she
wrote "The Hate U Give."
- I've read that, yeah.
- And the main character,
as you know, Star,
she goes to a predominantly white school,
and I happen to go to
predominantly white school too.
So, just seeing a girl who has-
- [Kelly] You saw
yourself in the character.
- Exactly. I saw myself in this character.
- That's incredible. Wow.
So, well, I have two people backstage
who have actually read
Gabrielle's short story.
'Cause you wrote a short story right?
- Yes, called the "Deadly Scavenger Hunt."
It's about a girl who has to compete
to get a scholarship for college.
- Okay, so, well,
both are number one New York
Times bestselling authors
and four of their books have
been turned into movies,
so they're pretty good at what they do.
They're what we call
a "Whole Lotta Woman."
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
So, Angie Thomas and Nicola
Yoon, come on out! (laughs)
(upbeat music)
(audience claps and cheers)
(Angie and Nicola laughing)
- What?!
- [Angie] It is so nice to meet you.
- It is so nice to meet you too.
- Oh my God.
- Hi.
- [Nicola] It's so nice to meet you.
- Oh my God.
(audience clapping)
That was perfect.
You like ended with black, and I was like,
"All right, segue."
(Angie laughing)
Have a seat. Oh my gosh.
So, both of you Red
Gabrielle's short story.
- Yes.
- So, any feedback,
what are you thinking?
- Oh my God.
That twist, that cliffhanger, like-
- Oh my God, you got us.
- Like, yeah, you got us.
Like, oh my goodness,
I could not write
anything like that at 15.
Your dialogue is amazing.
Your character development,
your twist, all of that.
Like you got it.
- Yeah, you really do.
- Thank you.
- The suspense.
Like I flew through that thing,
and at the end I was like hmm!
- [Angie] We won't spoil it.
- I was like, "Don't you spoil alert!"
- No, I will not.
- I wanna read it, so I
like a twist at the end.
So, what do you wanna say to these authors
that have inspired you?
- Just thank you for your
contribution to the world
and just showing Black
girls that we can do it too.
- Yes, we can.
- Absolutely!
(audience clapping)
I know you write, Poppy,
like what would you give
advice like on, you know,
just being a young writer, what
do you think is good advice?
- I mean, in the presence
of extraordinary writers,
I'm like "Ah!"
(all laughing)
Your life sounds like it's
been so fascinating already,
and, you know, you've got so much to tell.
You know, our movie is about my real life,
and I sort of tend to stick to what I know
and not be afraid to
tell the truth about it
'cause there's some
skeletons in the closet
that'll be in the sequel
to the first movie.
But, yeah, just not to be ashamed
of the things you think
people would judge,
that's sort of the stuff
that you tend to wanna throw out there.
- It's more relatable as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well, everybody,
remember to pick up a copy of "Whiteout"
wherever books are sold.
But for everyone in our audience,
you're so lucky you
don't have to do a thing
because you're all going home
with a copy of "Whiteout!"
(audience clapping and cheering)